i'm mortified i do understand why people
were upset
kim kardashian finally reacting to the
controversy surrounding this moment i
have the best advice for women in
business get your
up and work
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days those comments to variety back in
march caused an avalanche of backlash
for the reality star and now we know
what kim was thinking in the aftermath
thanks to our first look at the
kardashians season two you saw all of
the backlash on the variety interview
no one sympathizes with you
yeah the internet was not kind in that
moment
with celebs like soledad o'brien posting
messages like quote also be born rich
really helps
broadway star patty murren writing quote
if i could afford to produce my own
broadway show so that i could star in it
then yes i would think this is excellent
advice
and actress jamila jamil an avid
kardashian critic adding quote nobody
needs to hear your thoughts on success
slash work ethic this same 24 hours in
the day
is a nightmare
99.9 percent of the world grew up with a
very different 24 hours
you just gotta roll with it
seems like kim kept true to that
philosophy as she dealt with the
controversy you saw all of the backlash
on the variety interview
no one sympathizes with you
i'm mortified i do understand why people
were upset
you got this we're built for this you
know i love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
and behind the scenes isn't always bad
there are plenty of fun moments to look
forward to too
like this adorable exchange between kim
and her daughter north at a skim's photo
shoot with superstars tyra banks and
heidi klum
this is like such a dream come true you
have no idea how iconic this is you just
have no idea it's like her world
we also get a glimpse at kim's newfound
confidence seemingly born out of her
choice to divorce kanye west
it's been such a season of independence
i really feel like i found my personal
confidence
honey i'm the maryland and the jackie
there's different sides of me and i
obviously
still have to be happy and still have to
be me
in doing all of those things
um
so yeah
one side we don't get an eye on in this
trailer kim the girlfriend babe yeah do
you want to shower with me really
quick
that sees nearly broke the internet when
hulu dropped our first first look at
season two
but this time pete's mia from the
trailer
as we know keith called it quits earlier
this month after nine months of dating a
source told et that love is still there
for the two but they just work better as
friends
quote there's no drama or anything weird
between them now
he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
more than likely we will have to wait
until season three to see their split
but for now we can enjoy watching their
romance unfold when season two of the
kardashians premieres on september 22nd
season two is gonna be insanity here we
come this is my good side just let you
guys know
[Music]